let's go right into the first story this
is it right here it's from the western
journal
the story is written house prosecutor
violates gun safety points ar 15 with
finger on trigger at court full of
people why is it important
the prosecution was actually arguing
earlier on that there was a charge
potentially for kyle rittenhouse because
they claimed he aimed his weapon at
people which is like negligent disregard
for the safety of others something like
that
pointing a weapon at people was a
criminal offense they argued now here's
something funny
the prosecutor does this
i don't even know if we can show you the
footage of the photo of it and there's
multiple photos because youtube might
actually give us a strike for showing
him pointing a rifle at people but you
know what we're gonna do it anyway
because this is the prosecutor and if
youtube doesn't even allow us to show
the prosecutor aiming a rifle finger on
the trigger at a jury
then
we're in a whole world of hurt with
censorship so here it is
right here on the front of the screen
matt walsh says kenosha d.a pointed a
gun at the jury with his finger on the
trigger there's the image let me let me
let me blow it up let me get a bigger
here's a bigger one for you now this is
from behind this is from one of the
streams where you can see the prosecutor
in the kyle rittenhouse case aiming a
rifle at people now hold on
these photos don't actually show you who
he's pointing at why
because they can't show the jury the
jury's identity is kept secret they mute
the audio when they're talking with the
jury they send the jury in and out and
i'll even point out
i
don't believe it i just i'm i'm biased i
cannot believe it that he actually
pointed the rifle finger on the trigger
and i just got to say a couple more
things
here it is with his finger on the
trigger i believe i think i have a
bigger photo here look at this
finger on the trigger now there's no
magazine it doesn't matter there can be
a round in the chamber and someone could
easily put it in but i just want to
stress this point people like to talk
about how newsguard is biased it's
microsoft it's bill gates so i'm going
to show you right here
western journal according newsguard
has an 82 out of 100. the website mostly
adheres to basic standards of
credibility and transparency newsguard
says this is real news and they say the
prosecutor held an ar-15 rifle with his
finger on the trigger and pointed it
toward the jury
that this is definitive now tim i know
you don't believe it i do because number
one he's a government employee number
two he's chicken winging i remember the
first time i held a rifle before my
elbows were all the way up that's not
really the proper way to hold a rifle
you learn to kind of hold them down and
not act like you're doing the funky
chicken so uh i mean obviously i think
he was doing it for dramatic effect i
mean if i was sitting on the jury we
were talking about this you said you
you'd scream because you have a good
point to that you want someone with the
finger on the trigger let me clarify i
wouldn't scream like
i would yell get down and i'd shove
people to the floor there's a government
agent holding a firearm with his finger
on the trigger in your face that he
hasn't checked properly before even
picking up he didn't even do that he
didn't check it yeah he did it he asked
other people if they did this is baldwin
yeah alex baldwin as soon as i seen this
i was like was alec baldwin consulting
him
that's the question that i asked him
i have some personal experience with
this guy so i mean my personal
experience with him he seemed totally
unprepared for me when i went to go
testify the other day
and it just kind of seemed like he
wasn't really prepared for what he was
doing in this trial and i can't really
speak for him but looking at something
like this i mean how could you take
someone serious when they're talking
about
how you handle a firearm or the do's and
don'ts when you're speaking to the jury
when they display something like this in
a courtroom i mean i think he he was
trying to discredit me i think this
discredits himself he had you drew
hernandez reporter on the scene on the
stand as a as a fact witness not as an
expert witness as someone who's like i
was there i saw this and he started
questioning why you had a lawyer he
started questioning whether you were
biased who you worked for now not then
i'm hoping the jury can see through what
this guy has been doing
because
pointing a weapon at them i i think i
understand why he did it he was hoping
that they would feel a fear
and then be like wow is that what kyle
writtenhouse did to people he should be
in jail
he should be in jail not not kyle
rittenhouse
should be in jail no no no look it's i
think it's a misdemeanor charge to point
a weapon a british weapon at somebody
i don't see why he gets special
privileges in a courtroom putting his
finger on the trigger with a weapon he
did not check people are all you see all
these leftists all the i shouldn't say
lebanese because leftists like guns
establishment democrats and they're
going to be fair he did ask if it was
unloaded
that that's all he did that's it that's
not imagine imagine there's a bad actor
they don't like him he's a leftist and
when they when they when they check the
bolt they pop in a two two three and say
you're good to go and then he aims and
bang kills a juror
that risk should not be present in any
capacity a bunch of people i asked as
soon as i saw it happen i said why
didn't they lock the bolt back
just good point lock it back so we know
it's clear and it's not gonna fight
dude this is like a really bad video
game like this this this guy the alec
baldwin didn't check the magazine or he
didn't check the the chamber neither did
it and then like two weeks later this
guy didn't check the chamber and like
you said he seemed unprepared he seemed
like a stoner that went to theater
school
like like he was getting really high a
couple weeks ago yeah
and now he's like had it out of his
system for a while because he's got a
big trial up ahead or maybe he's on like
zoloft or something or some crazy like
slowing mechanism that because the guy
is like faded now i want to point out it
says that he pointed it toward the jury
that's different than at the jury so
maybe it's like above the jury down the
hallway past the jury well no no no the
western journal is reporting that he
pointed it directly no no it says toward
yeah but come on man what does toured
mean yeah in their direction
around the target right right right i
think that's a fair point but i also
think regardless it's still like if
there's a group of people and you're not
directly aiming at any one person you're
pointing it toward the group of dude you
didn't check the chamber at least have a
chamber flag i mean that's even common
sense as well but again
again he works with the government and i
i would be i would i'd run away
i want to point this out i want to point
this out here's what here's what i
tweeted i think anybody who knows guns
knows these rules
treat a gun always as if it is loaded
and here's his picture never pointed at
something you don't intend to destroy
keep your finger off the trigger until
you are ready to fire there's one i
didn't include in this
always know where your target is and
what is beyond it
so let's make the argument he didn't
actually point it at a jury with his
finger on the trigger
those walls are not going to stop a
rifle round and he has no idea who's
behind those people or behind that wall
or whatever
i think this discredits everything he's
saying about his arguments about guns
about bullets you know the defense made
a really really good point in their
closing arguments
it was richards defense uh who said
i've been in trials you know the
prosecution tries to call full metal
jacket as if it's a more threatening
round as if it matters he said i've been
in trials where they say you know to the
jury he used hollow points those are
designed to kill people whereas a full
metal jacket would just go through them
and they'd survive and now with carbon
house they're arguing the opposite
hollow points wouldn't have gone through
people and it wouldn't have been
reckless and he says regardless of that
the bullet is a bullet and making an
argument about the kind of bullet
irrelevant and here you have a guy who
tries to act like he knows what he's
talking about he doesn't know what he's
talking about you want something funny i
think it was kraus the other eight the
prosecutor who said there's no such
thing as a right or left-handed gun
it's amazing it's not true how they can
just say things without knowing what
they're talking about and the funny
thing is
i guess you can't actually object to
lies
for real so my understanding is the is
the the opponents can objecting your
closing arguments to matters of the
court so there was a moment where they
stated that the zaminsky's it's like
kelly and some other guy was named zach
i don't know i don't remember his first
name
he said they have a fifth amendment
right you know why didn't they testify
they objected to that saying they don't
have a fifth amendment right they could
have called the woman who was convicted
but the dude this is this is a really
important point in the trial
whether or not someone has a fifth
amendment right is up to the prosecution
did you guys know that no you think like
i plead the fifth no the prosecutor can
say then we grant you full immunity
start talking and if you don't you're in
contempt so when they say ziminski could
testify the the state the defense was
like we can't call him he can plead the
fifth but the state can grant immunity
and get whatever testimony they want
from him
and the judge would not
uh sustain the objection he sort of
sustained it he said we'll just ask you
to move on he didn't explain to the jury
that the state controls the ability of
fifth of of pleading the fifth so now
you have this guy who has no idea what
he's talking about they have power over
some of the witnesses they didn't
execute the search warrant on gauge
gross kreutz and they control whether or
not ziminski even testifies and here's
here's the point this is why it's
important
cal written house got the gun charge
dismissed we'll talk about that in a
second that's a huge victory but he
stated the prosecution stated that the
zamen
he pointed the gun at the zaminski's and
the defense said i don't see the
zaminsky's here and the judge said you
didn't call them as witnesses to testify
in the fact that a weapon was pointed
there's no complaining witness if i
can't see it happen i can't instruct the
jury that it did
very very important points yeah
hypothetically if if kyle did use hollow
points let's just kind of play up the
scenario i mean the scene would be so
much more graphic than it already was
and already
you saw the state prosecutor play
extremely graphic videos show extremely
graphic images during his closing
arguments that i couldn't even look at
like it like sparked a very strong
reaction to me so i do think when he was
doing his kind of theatrics putting his
finger on the trigger moving the rifle
around when he was showing you know the
bicep when he was showing the gore when
he was showing the blood i i think he
was trying to evoke more of an emotional
response rather than a logical one
because other than that i can't really
understand what he was really trying to
do here also there's a meme video going
around from the movie heat uh with his
image state kind of kind of imposed as
the state prosecutor in action that is
also going viral on the internet and i
just uh with him with the rifle yes with
him there's there's a lot of people we
can't show it yeah we can't i would i
really wanted to like luke's like look
at this thing i tweeted and i was like
we gotta we can't put that on youtube
you know here's a comment i wanna make
about the trial and
the reason why you're seeing this
prosecutor um
look really bad
time after time even the state's own
witnesses right gage came out and
literally admitted under oath he pointed
his gun at kyle first right the reason
why you're seeing this happen over and
over and over again is because the truth
is coming out it's coming out from the
prosecution it's coming out through the
defense as well and when you find
yourself trying to
suppress the truth or you find yourself
trying to dance around the truth or
combat against the truth to try and like
discredit it it's not gonna go well for
you and that's why you see this happen
over and over and over again in this
trial and people are just kind of like
what's going on with this guy what's
what's going on here because it's like
when you're trying to argue with the
truth and you're trying to discredit it
and make it look like it's not even
relevant or true or you you just try and
like take the jury away from that's what
he was trying to do with me he's trying
to take the jury away from what i was
going to testify take the jury distract
away ask me questions that would lead me
down another path
it doesn't go well for you and the
reason why it doesn't go well for you is
because it all comes out and when it
comes out people are going to know for
themselves what really happened that's
what's happening this is a big victory
in and of itself that it's televised
because
you know in a real system with just
malicious
malpractice of justice it would be it
would have been behind the scenes
kangaroo court one and done no one would
have seen it but we get to watch
all the malfeasance um i think that's a
victory whatever the outcome of the
church imagine this imagine imagine if
no videographers would have been there
that night oh yeah imagine where we
would be right now you know what's funny
is the narrative that's been spun the
president of the united states literally
used kyle rittenhouse as a poster child
for white supremacy in his campaign
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you